foreign
let's go to Patrick in Grand Rapids
what's up Patrick
hey Dr John how are you this show is
rapidly devolving so help us out man
balance to my life and kind of the
question I had was uh how can I better
prioritize my family kind of with
everything going on what you got going
on
uh so right now at this stage of my life
I'm in medical residency uh which means
I work a ton and I work like 70 to 80
hours a week
and so at a baseline I'm just not home
frankly as much as I'd like to be to
spend time with my family and even when
I am home
I just find myself thinking about people
I took care of that day or how I could
have better you know interacted with
somebody and so I'm not even even when
I'm there I'm not always mentally there
yeah absolutely
um and how much longer do you got in
residency
uh another two years okay and then where
to
uh I'm not really sure after that are
you are you doing a specialty post-doc
are you going directly into private
practice what are you gonna go do
so I'll be in family medicine and uh I
to you know help pay for some of the
school stuff I signed a government
contract so I'll be doing some
government work okay are you in the
service
uh yeah yep what's that commitment 100
years uh yeah forever
um from right now it's gonna be close to
nine years okay is that gonna have to be
is it gonna be full time is that gonna
be as needed no it's going to be full
time
okay
how much of this challenge are you
looking down the road and saying this is
going to be the next decade of my life
versus this is the next
um two years of my life
that uh I mean it's kind of both
um I mean I know what the next two years
look like I don't know what the next
time after the
okay it's really hard to think too much
about it because I don't know what the
state of the world's gonna look like or
where I'm going to be or where they're
going to send me oh so you can get
deployed over the next 10 years too
uh yeah yeah okay okay
how old are your kids man
uh just one on the way coming here soon
in a couple weeks congratulations man
that's exciting thanks it's exciting
um so
here's a couple things I think I would
keep in mind and a couple of
things that I had to navigate I never
went to med school but
there's some similar we've got some
similar trajectories and I'll walk you
through some of it the first thing is
you signed what's essentially
um you have 10 years left on the
commitment you signed
the faster you make peace with that
reality and don't fight it
the more energy you will have to spend
on adjusting your life and your schedule
and your routine and your overall
Wellness which allows you to be the dad
and husband you want to be it gives you
more energy and perspective on those
things that actually matter
the more you walk around pissed off that
you've got 10 more years and I don't
know where I'm gonna be and this and
that the the less time and focus you
have on the other stuff is that fair
yeah yeah absolutely so I think there's
something important about saying yeah
this is cool I get to serve my country
and I get to a kid and maybe more are
gonna get a ringside seat to what
service looks like both on at the
individual level taking care of an
individual patient
um at the community level at the
national level so I I think there's some
really remarkable insights that that um
you'll be able to pass on to your kids
how's your marriage man
uh I'm good I'm as good as it could be
with a nine month pregnant right yeah
yeah yeah absolutely you're in it right
so things are chaos
um how was it before
I could okay actually really good she's
she's the best thing that's ever
happened to me honestly have you ever
asked her
how she sees you doing
I don't think in those specific terms as
much no it was an important uh moment
for my marriage when my wife looked me
in the eye and said I'm tired of
watching my husband die right before my
eyes
because I was working myself to death
and she had never spoken that directly
to me before but there was something
powerful to the point that now I ask her
at some regular intervals
how am I looking but not like it I'm not
posing down I'm not all oiled up and
flexing but how am I looking she'll say
man you look great like
you're present with us or I'm giving her
permission to say I haven't seen you in
three weeks even though I've been home
every night see what I'm saying so
sometimes if you have a good connection
with your wife she can be a remarkable
mirror for
the man that she loves right right
before her okay so
um
here's what I've had to do over the
years
is I've had to create an off-ramp for
myself between
working in the messy lives of people
showing up for clients or patients
whatever you want to call them showing
up in crisis situations and then showing
up for my wife and kids
and you're gonna have to learn that
toggle between dealing with somebody
coding somebody telling a loved one that
their loved one has died and then
showing up to a soccer game
hard
and so I would recommend strongly over
the next few years creating a practice
that you can live by that's going to
give you the tools to be able to shut
this sucker down this person passed away
today I wish I'd been kinder to this
woman I wish I'd told this woman that
she has cancer in a different way
I'm going to learn that I'm going to
have a process I'm going to have a
journal where I write this down I'm
going to write myself a small note that
says I forgive you and next time we're
going to do better and I'm closing this
journal and this part of my day is over
and now I'm gonna go be with my family
and that's just I just made that one up
on the spot it can be a quick stop at a
gym at a gym it could be going to grit
get um coffee sometimes I call friends
on the way home I have a 30 minute
commute and it's become really important
for me because it allows me to shut
these calls off and then go home and be
present with my kids but at the end of
the day it's you being intentional about
a process and choosing I'm not going to
bring my patients into my house
you there yeah yep I'm here does that
sound does that sound possible or does
that sound crazy no no I think I think
that's great I I don't think I know
really the balance yet on uh yeah
sharing things with my wife about my day
and how much just to like leave at the
hospital
I can tell you from personal experience
I almost buried my wife with my garbage
and I with the details of my garbage and
I almost broke my marriage up when I
decided to go the other way and hold all
of it to myself
and so the balance that I've struck in
my house and so like for there's not I
don't know any clinical data that would
suggest otherwise you and your wife can
have to figure out what's best for y'all
um some Partners may want to hear more
details Others May like I don't want to
know
um my wife and I landed on hey I had a
really rough night last night
or at a really tough session yesterday
and then my wife knows it's hard
and
um but she doesn't have to watch me
carry on the hey I had my hands inside
of a patient yesterday as they bled out
or I had to tell a mom that her
four-year-old son had died some of the
horrific things I've had to do
I I or and you will have to do and you
have done that's a lot of burden to put
on somebody and this is gonna sound
crazy when I say it like this
our bodies have a built-in mechanism for
dealing with reality in front of us it
has less of an ability to reconcile it
when it's just info meaning when you are
with somebody saving their life doing
CPR your body is cycling through
cortisol and adrenaline and
it is pumping through your body you have
an exit release you are running you are
moving you're reading charts you are in
this thing and those chemicals are
cycling through your body as they should
you come home and sit down and dump that
story on your wife
and those chemicals discharge in her
even at a lesser degree they got nowhere
to go
right you see what I'm saying and so but
again every couple's different are you
feeling her getting burned out
I think I'm probably more on the other
end where I just don't tell her anything
and she's uh she's waiting for me to
tell her something about my day please
don't please don't do that come please
don't do that you'll create an alternate
you'll create an alternative life for
yourself that's apart from your wife
and it's a tricky balance make no
mistake it's a tricky balance
and when you have a kid when your kid
comes and your kid can can y'all can
start having conversations in three or
four years there'll be something really
important about saying Daddy had a
really hard day today
here to see some things that were sad
that's such a gift to your kids
okay
um but coming home and saying man I saw
somebody whose hand got cut off like
that's not going to be helpful to a
five-year-old right right right so it's
finding that balance but
um
yeah I mean I
give your wife the gift of letting her
love you
and I guess maybe sit down and ask her
what that means and y'all maybe I'll can
figure it out together
yeah why are you nervous about it no I
guess I just need to sit down with her
and figure out like how much she wants
to know and what is like what is
getting a better gauge from her of what
is too much because I part of me is
afraid that like I don't want her to
I don't want her to experience some of
the things that I have and even if it's
secondhand from me like I don't want to
feel like a burden to her
or like my my burdens become her burdens
there it is right there
she signed up to carry your arms in the
desert when you can
and you sign that up for her
and so don't don't take her love for you
away
and there's a way to be abusive with
that Insight right there's a way that I
mean you can you could shut a party down
pretty quick right
yeah yeah yeah you and if you're like me
you probably have on a cake you you
sound like somebody who's got a little
more diplomacy than I do I learned early
on oh I should never tell these stories
to anybody I think I've uh I've slipped
up a little one too many times and so I
I tend to withhold yeah listen you will
never be a burden to your wife
unless you come home and just start
throwing blood and guts in her face and
she has asked you not to do that
um
in fact it becomes more of a burden if
you hide yourself from her that's
burdensome
because she's gonna walk around
wondering what she did wrong that keeps
her from being trustworthy to you
she's gonna walk around all day
wondering
what it is about her that you don't love
enough to have a story uh to invite her
into your life that's burdensome
but coming home and telling her hey I
had a really hard hard day
what I really need is fill in the blank
I really need to hold your hand and
watch TV and put our feet up and let's
eat
let's eat shamefully tonight
let's just get off the rails
or what I really need is for you and I
to go for a walk or I need 30 minutes by
myself I saw some hard things today to
have some tough conversations and it was
really bad
and
man what a gift that can be let her love
you let her love you let her love you
and don't fight this commandment you got
10 years you got 10 years and you're
gonna be upset when you have to miss
t-ball games and dance recitals you're
gonna that's hard stuff
and the other side of it is you get to
live a life of service and purpose that
millions and millions and millions of
people are desperate for right now
because they're walking aimlessly around
waiting for AI to take their job
and
you've made a commitment bigger than
yourself to say I love people I'll never
meet and I'm willing to go first and so
I'm grateful for you man thank you so
much for the call brother